[Music]
please don't tell me this lord please
Jesus don't tell me that he's gone
please don't tell me that he's gone
please officer don't tell me that you
just did this to him you shot four
bullets into him sir
he was just getting his license tree and
registration sir when I opened the video
the part that showed was falando you
know holding himself in bleeding out my
first reaction was holy I hope he
doesn't die once I found out that he did
my reaction was this is a murder on film
again here we go again
live streaming maybe one of the reasons
that the police shootings have taken on
such urgency people now see somebody
getting shot in real time and instead of
it being a statistic it's a real thing
that they have to grapple with there's
three days of violence it was like a
hammer to your heart every day there's
been a lot of people shot a lot of
police shootings why are we focusing on
these three days clearly one of the main
reasons is the degree to which the
videos went viral
with the Sterling case we see multiple
people using their phones to record with
video it's not live streaming but they
post that so they can be seen by others
in their social network you thought him
get his ID sir his driver's license oh
my god please don't tell me he's dead
July 6 July 6 felt like a punch in the
gut because we learned about ultimate
sterling you know we saw his face
we saw his kids and then we heard about
Lando Castile he was trying to get out
his ID his wallet out in the castile
case his girlfriend used the live
streaming technology to actually show it
happening in real time and having it
posted on her newsfeed the Philander
Castile video of course was one of the
most upsetting things to see the vast
majority of police shootings never even
get a headline in the national media why
did the Castile shooting because it was
such an incredibly dramatic thing to
watch a man die those videos and the
subsequent reaction by black lives
matter by politicians created the
perfect storm for this Massacre July 7
there were the shootings in Dallas and
that felt like absolutely
all of a sudden people that were talking
about change that we're talking about
police accountability no longer felt
comfortable or safer able to have that
conversation because through that that
shooting from you know a lone wolf or
somebody that for my understanding was
mentally ill came this narrative that
the movement for black lives is again a
terrorist threat is is out there
advocating for the shooting a police
officers when that wasn't what was
happening in those three days we saw
something different because we had this
live stream footage the availability of
real-time videos has had a tremendous
effect on law enforcement some of it
negative some of it positive some of
these videos being put out on all these
social media platforms they don't tell
the whole story because by the time
somebody is filming the action has
already begun technology and media both
hurt and help the cause in a number of
ways I think one of the things that you
see is positive is this ability to
document stories to challenge a
mainstream narrative but I also think
technology can hurt in a number of ways
I worry that more and more we are
becoming numb and desensitized to some
of these videos
I think that Facebook and Twitter and
and these gatekeepers have a huge role
one of the challenges that these
companies now face as they are in the
role of news maker and news editors even
though that's not what they want to be
in the Casteel video that was taken down
briefly and then and put back up I have
a lot of empathy actually for in this
case Facebook I think they're facing new
decisions that corporations and even
society haven't faced before we have to
consider what it means for companies to
hold our stories our next move is to
make sure that we have black platforms
to make sure that we have black autonomy
to make sure that we have black media
that we own to control our stories video
can be fantastic evidence it can show
police misconduct not everybody is out
there 24/7 doing the right thing
the unfortunate nature of what we have
seen is that these little pieces of
violent video make the police look like
they are the aggressors a snippet of
video doesn't tell the whole story I
don't think any one side can tell the
complete story but I think we're telling
the most truthful story people bring
their own perceptions to that video and
see very different things
so although video is incredibly powerful
it doesn't take away our unconscious
bias where it not for some form of live
video I think we would not know any of
these names having to watch these videos
every day it can be traumatic and yet I
know that if we aren't willing to look
at who we are as a country and what
we're allowing then change never happens